Eye Witness testimony,
uh,
of course is the single greatest cause
of the conviction of the innocent.
And what's fascinating about that is
that,
uh,
we have now,
um,
30 years,
more than 30 years of fantastic research
from experimental psychologists who
have,
uh,
you know,
recreated crime scene.
We recreated a events and,
uh,
played around with which different way
we do a photo array or a lineup and
different techniques that are used
correlate more with accurate and
reliable identifications in which,
uh,
techniques lead to errors.
And,
uh,
a number of reforms have been,
adopted,
uh,
by federal
commissions and the American Bar
Association,
the International Association of Chiefs
of Police,
lots of policing entities based on
really good scientific research.
I mean,
a lot of this research,
there's Meta analyses a,
that's where you pulled together lots of
different studies,
um,
and you have a lot of confidence that
certain things,
uh,
are real effects.
And I'll give you some examples.
Uh,
that may surprise people.
Um,
for example,
before you show somebody a photo array
or a live lineup,
he should tell the witness.
Um,
we're now going to show you some
pictures or people,
uh,
please keep in mind that the real
perpetrator may or may not be in this
photo array or a lineup.
And if you don't make an identification,
don't worry,
the investigation will continue.
Just giving that morning,
uh,
dramatically reduces incorrect
identifications without really reducing
correct identifications.
And that's of extraordinary importance
obviously in terms of being able to go
out,
find the real perpetrator and not arrest
the wrong person.
Uh,
uh,
there's lots of reasons we think that
this warning will reduce era.
Uh,
certainly it inhibits people from
guessing and,
uh,
there's kind of a natural inclination to
do that.
Um,
another reform that's of really critical
importance is that the person that
administers the lineup of the photo
array should be double blinded.
That is to say that the person should
not know who,
uh,
the suspect is.
Um,
uh,
and that's important for many reasons,
not the least of which is the
possibility
of,
uh,
feedback,
um,
confirming feedback.
What again,
Meta analyses have shown is that if you
say to somebody off you picked that
number too good or it gives some kind of
confirming feedback,
whether a law enforcement person or
somebody else.
Frankly,
what this does is it can falsely inflate
at the person's certainty that they made
the correct identification,
the witnesses belief that they had a
good opportunity to observe the
witnesses belief that they were paying
attention when the crime was committed.
Um,
all of these factors,
by the way,
certainty,
opportunity to observe paying attention
are all factors that the courts used to
be using or use frankly,
and trying to weigh the reliability of
identification when we know that let's
say some suggestive procedure has been
used.
So positive,
uh,
confirming feedback or even just the use
of an unduly suggestive procedure can
falsely inflate these so called
reliability factors,
uh,
certainty,
opportunity to observe,
attention paid.
And,
uh,
the legal tests are out of whack with
what the scientific evidence shows
more than a year ago.
Now,
the National Academy of Sciences came
out with a report about forensic
science,
generally extremely important report,
a landmark report that anybody really
interested in this field should look at.
Um,
and this report,
uh,
basically said,
look,
DNA testing is the only validated a
forensic discipline we have.
Um,
and in particular,
when you look at pattern evidence,
and by this they were talking about
fingerprints and tire tracks and looking
at the striations on bullets and trying
to determine just it gives me whether
they came from a gun,
particular gun or not.
Um,
all these,
uh,
pattern disciplines had not been
adequately validated,
uh,
because she would have,
an,
uh,
an experts coming into court and they'd
say,
I'm looking at the striations of this
bullet that we recovered from the crime
scene.
And now I found this defendant's gun.
And I fired a bullet from that.
And I'm looking at the two of them under
a microscope,
and I see all these lines and I think
there's quote unquote sufficient
agreement.
And by that.
And if I'm really a big quality
assurance lab,
I'll bring my buddy and,
and he'll look at the microscope and
he'll say,
I think there's also agreement here.
And from this I can now tell you that
this bullet came from that gun to the
exclusion of all other guns in the
universe.
Well,
think about it scientifically.
On what basis do you have a database?
Can you tell us anything about the
frequency of firing similar patterns if
indeed you have similar patterns?
Do you have measurement area here?
Can you give us a number?
You know,
with DNA testing we can give you a
number,
we can give you the frequency of a
particular DNA profile and the various
different populations.
Can you give us a statistic?
Um,
and the answer is no.
They weren't giving statistics.
As a matter of fact,
they were just saying it's unique.
This bullet comes from that gun to the
exclusion of all guns in the universe.
This is nonsense.
And the National Academy of Science said
so and so,
you guys are really got to go back to
the drawing board and do some basic
research.
Uh,
to find out what the answers are to that
question.
Even fingerprints,
um,
which we know I,
if you take all 10,
uh,
prints and you scan it in and you put it
into a data,
the database of known,
uh,
fingerprints,
you can do a pretty good job of
identifying somebody.
But that's not the question.
When you're talking about a small latent
print that a crime scene,
you get a partial thumbprint,
let's say,
and every time you lay down a print,
it's always a little bit uneven and then
you compare it to somebody else's thumb
print.
Can you say that this small latent
uniquely comes from that individual?
Well,
uh,
that is the way the testimony was going
in for years.
And it was a,
uh,
that scientific basis to say that it
uniquely was this person's print.
You can't say that.